for more confirmed cases of the corona
virus have been discovered there are now
440 confirmed cases where the outbreak
started in Wuhan the virus can be spread
through human contact I'm in central
China where a deadly new strain of
corona virus has emerged the outbreak
has sparked memories of the SARS virus
which also came from China which killed
nearly 800 people worldwide so what is
it and more importantly can we stop it
most corona viruses infect animals knock
people over the last seventy years
scientists have discovered corona
viruses in mice rats dogs cats bats
turkeys horses pigs and cattle in rare
cases like this one it can make the leap
from animal to human and then human to
human and it's in this market that
authorities believe a deadly new strain
of corona virus emerged it's now been
shuttered and authorities say
disinfected scientists don't yet
understand why only certain corona
viruses are able to infect people well
they do know is that the virus can make
people sick where symptoms like a runny
nose sore throat headache and fever for
those with a weakened immune system it
can cause bronchitis or pneumonia and
doesn't respond to antibiotic treatment
we heard about super spreaders during
the SARS epidemic those were people who
for whatever reason ended up spreading
the disease to a lot of people well this
isn't a super spreader person this is a
super spreader event and that brings a
lot of risk it is absolutely critical
that public health authorities recognize
a super spitting event the very most
human coronaviruses caused any mild to
moderate ailments but a handful are
known to be deadly
SARS also started here in China before
spreading quickly to other East Asian
countries killing about one in ten
people infected those over 65 were
particularly vulnerable SARS his full
name is severe acute respiratory
syndrome and other than death it also
causes fatigue diarrhea shortness of
breath and kidney failure Middle Eastern
respiratory syndrome MERS appeared in
2012 when he made the leap from camels
to humans killing 858 people
like the common cold there's no cure for
human coronavirus so if you feel sick
stay at home and avoid contact with
others live animals are especially
dangerous in this case so if you do come
into contact with live animals wash your
hands straight afterwards in terms of
human-to-human spread work we've spread
by coughing by sneezing even by a
handshake or by touching something that
someone with coronavirus has touched so
stay away from people who are sick and
disinfect any surfaces you think might
be at risk cover your mouth when you
cough and sneeze and wash your hands
often most humans will recover from
coronavirus by themselves
[Music]